autre réunion qui a lieu ce lundi celle
de l'assemblée générale des nations
unies les 193 membres de l'onu se
réunissent en session extraordinaire
d'urgence pour se prononcer sur le
conflit et débattre d'une résolution
condamnant l' invasion de l'ukraine par
la russie je vous propose d'écouter à
l'ambassadeur de la france a à l'onu
la chape et c'est cela aussi persiste
dans cette agression malgré le plan
initial de déstabilisation n
cela a échoué nous le voyons tous
il est extrêmement alarmant que le
président russe ont recours au chantage
nucléaire
nous vivons des événements loin d'être
ordinaire nous devons donc prendre des
mesures extraordinaires face à cette
menace qui pèse sur notre système
international et faire tout notre
possible pour aider l'ukraine et spip il
faut re seront un projet de résolution 3
la fin des hostilités et à la protection
des civils aient un accès humanitaire
sécurisé pour répondre aux besoins
urgents de la population est au mythe de
john keats de population
bruno daroux pourquoi une telle réunion
c'est que les résolutions de l'assemblée
générale de l'onu ne sont pas
contraignantes est ce que c'est un moyen
pour les états unis et leurs alliés de
montrer à quel point la russie se
retrouve isolé sur la scène
internationale
oui absolument d'abord c'est quand même
une assemblée générale extraordinaire
donc c'est quand même une procédure très
rare ce sera simplement la onzième fois
depuis 1950 qu'une telle procédure est
utilisée c'est pas c'est pas une réunion
normale si vous voulez donc ce côté déjà
extraordinaire montrent que la situation
est également extraordinaire et il
s'agit effectivement de faire le
décompte des pays qui sont pour ou
contre la russie il s'agit évidemment
pour le camp occidental de contraindre
l'ensemble des pays à se prononcer sur
ce qu'est en train de faire la russie
car ces assemblées générales vous l'avez
dit c'est non contraignant mais
symboliquement ça ça a quand même
beaucoup d'importance et surtout il n'y
a pas de droit de veto donc en fait
chacun vote vraiment selon ses
convictions est ce qu'on espère en fait
du côté occidental si j'ai bien compris
c'est que s'il ya plus d'une centaine de
pays sur 193 qui condamne la russie ce
sera un nouvel échec diplomatique pour
moscou après alors les deux résolutions
qui ont été voter pour celle de sécurité
au cours du week-end où la russie a été
le seul pays à voter contre en opposant
son veto puisqu'elle dispose du droit de
veto même des pays supposés alliés amis
ou non hostile comme la chine ou l'inde
n'ont pas voté avec la russie se sont
contentés de s'abstenir mer